hey there by Liz and welcome to another
video this one now in high definition
better wetting and better sound quality
hopefully so yeah I was very fortunate
and some nice guys have helped me get it
set up with some new lighting equipment
and new camera and hopefully that means
I can now bring you the same videos but
now in higher quality high fidelity
you're probably noticing pause and spots
on my face that you never noticed before
but that I was all too aware of so yes
we'll see how it goes and I was going to
make my first video in this new higher
definition in high quality a workout
video because that is still the main
focus of the channel but it turns out
that I am ill I was bitten by a bug and
that bite got infected with cellulitis
so I couldn't walk on it so I took
antibiotics which would you know help me
clear it up and have an allergic
reaction to the antibiotics so I now
have a nice rash on my neck
so no exertion today instead I'm going
to be reviewing this new trick
neurotropic limitless brain serve space
make smarter or at least more aware and
alert let's see if it works
cue the new opener
say yeah that's the new opener I am
aware that the old opener was nicked
from call of duty which is annoying
because I didn't make I know I paid
someone else to make it and what they
did was they went and they stole it from
there and put my name on it so that's
real nice real nice so I've made this
once at the man myself
cartoon about the bio medium is origin
story and maybe it sucks but it's
working progress let me know you think
I'll keep developing it so anyways on to
limitless brain this is a neurotropic
step meaning that it's not just one
ingredient it is a selection of
brilliant selected by the makers I
believe we're all so-called limitless
brain yeah I'm gonna super drive
supplements they said mr. review which
is very nice of them and normally I'm
going to be Asst of this kind of thing
because I've tried a whole bunch of
other ones and been very impressed they
either sticking so much stuff that
you're not actually getting any decent
quantities you know they just want a
really long looking list of ingredients
and there's barely any milligrams of
each thing in there
either that or they're sticking in all
sorts of stuff that I can't really
recommend like one of them had a draft
million I think us IQs all and I draft
another's basically like modafinil it's
not tested long-term modafinil
is a prescription only medicine whether
or not you agree with that that's the
fact of the matter you shouldn't really
just stick knitting stuff without
explaining it so a lot of these people
are popping up nootropics of popular at
the moment and they're trying to make
some money off of it and that's what I
assumed this might be but actually I'm
quite impressed with this one and I
really like it which is why I'm
reviewing it here so what you've got in
here is where caffeine and our feeling
which is your basic very most basic
nutrients step that a lot of beginners
use it's the same combination that's
found naturally in green tea the
caffeine wakes you up or thinning takes
the edge off
very less nervous etc our tyrosine to
boost Dec me have bacopa herb pile de
Torre alpha GPC so butylene & hué
cuisine a so some of those will boost
your a sitar choline in the brain you've
got a couple of things there that work
to do that the alpha GPC in the
huperzine a you've got things that boost
energy like the salty to me but it's all
naturally occurring stuff there's
nothing in here that's going to cause
say tolerance and dependence which i'm
not a fan of there's nothing that's
going to make you really wired the thing
that's most oxidized the caffeine so
it's quite a gentle natural combination
but i find that it's actually just
enough with the other tyrosine and
things in there just enough to actually
feel the difference so just feel a bit
more focused miss gentle but I think
that's how many trade it should be if
you're hoping to feel something if
you're hoping to feel strange then you
know you're looking in the wrong place
that someone who jokes about your trade
which happens feel like you on a good
day and this is basically it's basically
nutrition but with a couple of things
that will boost your energy levels in
there might actually like it and right
so I went into it a little bit skeptical
but I found myself actually wanting to
use it and this is the first nootropic
staff especially the first rounded one
that I can use on a regular basis for a
long time so I like this one why don't
like is the name limitless brain
obviously sounds a lot like for film
limitless and the TV series limitless
and that seems a bit of a cynical
marketing ploy to me it's just you know
company name don't buy off the success
of something else but whatever you know
that try make money
fair enough and then also I'm not a big
fan of caffeine in any of these things I
always suspect that the caffeine in
there to try and you know make you feel
like it's doing something but actually
you can get caffeine very cheaply very
easily why do you need it in your pot I
like to start my day with a coffee
I need to buy coffee because I sit in
coffee shops to work and if I'm having
coffee and then this that's now you know
200 milligrams ish of caffeine in my
system before I've even begun so you
know for me that's not great that's a
personal preference it does make sense
in this case
for the caffeine because it nicely
balances with the l-theanine and that's
something that regular user might not
know to do themselves
so I can sort of see it I'm just giving
my fault honest appraisal there and the
other thing I didn't like at first was
that it was a proprietary blend meaning
they didn't tell you the quantities
meaning oh is it all just caffeine and
then like one milligram of the rest but
I mentioned this in my original review
on the website and the makers emailed me
and they gave me the full list of the
ingredients so and they're actually you
know decent quantities so you know and I
back it up what I was finding myself I
thought a bit more focused bit more
willing to get on with my work without
distractions and had a little bit more
vigilance later on in the day so yeah I
really like it and I'm gutted when it
runs out but it's not cheap and yeah I
don't spend all my money on it but I
might well put it another wallet so
that's that's my most positive review of
a new trip it everything so that's good
cut that down there so yeah I hope you
enjoyed that hope you like in the new
quality of the setup pen if you notice
the difference
setting up white box is really difficult
especially when you're limping but yeah
there's going to be much more content
come to the site about laser ideas and
interesting things are going to talk
about what is your fitness philosophy
talk about how to create an athletic
profile for yourself and talking about
the nature of consciousness introversion
versus extraversion and how you can
change that new traffic ingredients that
make me evil workouts many workouts
outdoor nature workouts workouts for
your legs that you can do at home
without equipment etc I've got so much
more stuff coming so stay tuned and yeah
thanks very much for watching this and
I'll see you next time bye for now